on the 9th of may 2022 at the moscow
victory day parade contrary to
expectations vladimir putin did not
escalate the war in ukraine there was no
declaration of war no announcement of
general mobilization no nuclear threat
no escalation whatsoever uk secretary of
defense ben wallace suggested that putin
might be looking for a way out u.s
intelligence suggested on the other hand
that putin might be looking to escalate
after all how will this war end how will
we ever get back to normal whatever that
means from this point putin really
painted himself into a corner with his
special military operation by refusing
to admit that it's a war he couldn't
mobilize russian society and had only
limited resources for the war which was
of course supposed to be a blitzkrieg
originally with western support only
increasing and ukrainian morale
remaining very high the war has turned
into an absolute disaster for the
russian army but putin cannot back out
just like that years and years of
propaganda have made sure that russian
society will not accept just pulling out
of ukraine and would experience it as
utter humiliation what russia couldn't
defeat a weak and pathetic ukraine run
by drug-addicted neo-nazis impossible
and so at this point vladimir putin has
three choices let's go over them after a
word from today's sponsor atlas vpn
atlas vpn offers a service that encrypts
your data and hides your virtual
location from prying eyes it helps you
protect your privacy and allows you to
bypass those ever annoying region locks
with atlas vpn you'll be able to unlock
all that content locked away from you
arbitrarily only based on your location
like on netflix and other streaming
platforms all you need to do is open the
app pick a server and that's it atlas
vpn also includes a breach scanner
function able to tell you if there are
any data leaks associated with a given
email address atlas vpn also allows you
to block unwanted trackers from websites
with their new tracker blocker feature
all you need to do is flip the switch
currently atlas vpn is running a huge
discount for their three-year plan for
just 199 dollars per month with one
extra month for free using the code adam
something and of course with a 30 day
money back guarantee the link is in the
description atlas of course runs both on
desktop and mobile and is compatible
across all well-known operating systems
protect your privacy and don't let
region blocks stop you take advantage of
this discount today by clicking the link
in the description thank you for
checking out atlas vpn ads like this
helps support what i do and now back to
the video
right now putin's choices are the
following a consolidate gains and force
a peace accord and sell it back home as
a victory b trying to rally more of
russia's resources to aid the war effort
and try to overwhelm ukraine after all
or c opt for a nuclear escalation first
off i'd like to address the issue many
find most pressing the threat of nuclear
war is it real or not this threat has
been used by pro-russian actors or
people who are just plain terrified to
try and stop military aid to ukraine for
fear of a nuclear exchange that infamous
open letter from german intellectuals to
the chancellor also cites the threat of
nuclear war as a big reason why we
should do appeasement essentially but is
there a threat of a global nuclear war
the short answer no there isn't nato
will not nuke russia so when it comes to
global nuclear war the ball is in
russia's court and for russia to nuke
nato countries puji needs the consent of
the general staff which is unlikely to
happen and this is one of those hidden
benefits of having a kleptocratic elite
that only cares about money and power
and don't have any strong beliefs or
values otherwise also according to
russian doctrine there are four main
scenarios where they would use nukes the
use of nuclear weapons or wmds against
russia or its allies data showing the
launch of ballistic missiles aimed at
russia or its allies an attack on
critical government or military sites
that would undermine the country's
nuclear force's response actions and the
use of conventional weapons against
russia when the very existence of the
state is in jeopardy based on these not
even indirect russian nato engagement in
ukraine would automatically mean nuclear
war i mean don't get me wrong the
chances would be much higher but this is
only to illustrate how simply sending
weapons to ukraine is not really an
issue in terms of triggering a nuclear
war so with the threat of global nuclear
escalation discounted what will happen
as i mentioned on the victory day parade
there was no declaration of war no
announcement of general mobilization no
escalation whatsoever and this is
interesting because russia isn't doing
so well in ukraine right now sure they
are a danger but the name of the game
here is sustainability their best troops
have been in the game since the
beginning along with their best
equipment and they won't get resupplied
anytime soon replacement equipment and
personnel are inferior to what they are
replacing on top of this ukrainians are
now switching to active counter-attacks
around horkief russians initially work
to encircle the city now they are
struggling to stay even within artillery
range with some reports saying they are
already out of artillery range as
ukrainians seem to be plowing all the
way to the border in the southwest
around hairson the front lines have
frozen solid russians are launching
artillery barrages to pin defenders
while ukrainians are plotting to take
care of itself and no mario paul is
still not fully taken by the way at this
point putin can either grab as much
territory as he can and force a peace
agreement or try to double down and turn
the conflict into a long-term low
intensity war just like the war in
dunbas in the long-term case putin would
be banking on the fact that western
support would decline over time this is
unlikely ironically due to the
exotically brutal atrocities committed
by russian troops in ukraine as such
abandoning support for ukraine would be
a hard sell in any western democracy
long-term plans might involve transistor
to some extent on paper anyway though
that's rather doubtful if so russians
really couldn't do much beyond some
local rebel rousing as they only have a
couple of thousand troops there of
questionable effectiveness if putin goes
short term then he'll likely try to
simply hold what he already got it's
hard to tell at this point if he is
actually doing this because russia's
offensive has effectively stalled
[Music]
so
right now in ukraine russia is left with
the east and southeast as far as i can
tell this is why russia will keep
focusing all their efforts for now the
east being the primary objective and the
southeast being the secondary if this is
the case and it sure looks like it is
putin has finally revised his objectives
into only taking doing scandals regions
and maintaining their gains in the south
to keep the land bridge to crimea open
basically it's another attempt at the
novorossiya project which ended up
failing back in 2015 but now the russian
military itself is supposed to finish
the job though it's a far more modest
version than the original plans so putin
will either cut his losses now and
declare mission accomplished that's the
short-term variant or go long-term in
which case he'll try to bleed ukraine
out as he tried originally using the
donbass of course putin's choice is
influenced by how well the russian army
is doing on the ground since if they are
getting absolutely demolished with no
hope of a positive turn putin might just
become more amicable to peace talks that
being said it seems that this war will
ultimately be decided on artillery most
of everything else will be a supporting
factor and bad news for russia ukraine
has already deployed their first m777
howitzers this is a big deal in essence
because the things can shoot much
farther than russian artillery with
guided munitions the range can go up to
40 kilometers as you can see on this
graph there is quite a difference there
all this means is more destroyed supply
convoys more destroyed positions more
lost equipment than personnel and so on
developments like this will likely lead
to ukrainians starting to reclaim more
and more territory as time goes on
though they don't have the manpower for
an all-out counter-offensive they are
resorting to localized constant
harassment and incremental progress
so-called shaping operations designed to
put the russian leadership in front of
difficult choices through limited
small-scale safe but very destructive
attacks but here's the kicker ukrainian
troops cannot take back too much
territory because then they would be
risking an actual chemical attack or
tactical nuclear strike by russia this
means crimea and the originally occupied
areas in the donbass are off limits
probably chances are russians will only
be able to make incremental gains in the
donbass and likely no gains at all in
the south around crimea i don't think
there will be any dramatic territorial
shifts any time soon except around
hardkiv my personal opinion is that
ukraine will end up ceding both the
donbass and crimea and maybe part of the
south that's a big maybe there in
exchange putin can declare victory and
finally put an end to this embarrassment
he calls a special military operation
it's also possible that ukraine will
only defect oc territories to end the
war as in all but officially stating it
which would mean sanctions against
russia will remain in place since at
that point technically russia is still
occupying ukrainian territory of course
puji might also be going for the long
term which means a low intensity
conflict like the donbass war
potentially for multiple years to come
but i think as things stand currently
that's a less likely scenario but it's
still possible so let's not discount it
just yet either way the pace of the war
will likely stay slow in terms of
territorial gain the russian army is
beaten and exhausted and without mass
mobilization soon they'll have to start
digging in to defend at that point there
will either be a sort of peace accord or
the beginning of a frozen or low
intensity conflict in my opinion either
way we shall see in the meantime thank
you for watching and don't forget to
like and subscribe and i also have a
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and i'll be seeing you
on the next occasion